[Music]
welcome back today we're very lucky to
be here in the Berkeley Graduate School
of Journalism and joined by Rebecca
Skloot who is a visiting writer and
residence here in Rebecca of course is
the author of the best-selling and
award-winning book The Immortal Life of
Henrietta Lacks and no exaggerations say
this is the most important book written
for a public audience in the history of
bioethics it's we're incredibly lucky to
be joined by here today welcome Rebecca
thank you thanks for having me so
Rebecca I know you've been asked this
many times and of course everybody
should read this wonderful book but can
you give us the short form story of
Henrietta Lacks and the HeLa cells yeah
absolutely
so we're I always like to start is just
with HeLa so the word HeLa is spelled h
ee l a and it's an abbreviation for
Henrietta's name eg for Henrietta L a
relaxed and Henrietta was a poor black
tobacco farmer who grew up in southern
Virginia and in 1951 when she was 30
years old she was diagnosed with
cervical cancer at this point she had
moved up to Baltimore and she went to
Johns Hopkins which was the only
Hospital where she could actually get
treated because she was a black woman
and this was this you know is the era of
segregation so she was seen in what's
called the public Ward which was where
you went if you were black or poor and
you couldn't afford to be treated
anywhere else so she went to Hopkins and
before treating her cancer without
telling her her doctor just cut a little
piece of her tumor and put that in a
dish and he sent that down the hall to
George guy who was the head of tissue
culture research at Hopkins and George
guy along with scientists all around the
world had been trying to grow human
cells outside the body for decades and
it had never worked they could survive a
few days maybe a few weeks but they all
died pretty quickly and for reasons that
remained a mystery for decades
Henrietta cells just never died so they
pretty quickly just started exploding
they doubled their numbers every 24
hours and they went from like two dishes
to four to eight to 16 and they sort of
pretty quickly took over the lab and
when George guy realized this he started
calling all these scientists and
saying I think I have the first immortal
human cell line which is what they're
called which means they will just grow
and divide forever in the lab as long as
you keep him warm and you feed them and
keep them clean in response all these
scientists said great can we have some
and he said yes and so he would send
these cells to other scientists who
would then grow them in their lab and
give them to their friends who'd give
him to their friends and Henrietta cells
spread around the world this way very
inefficient system for doing this and so
pretty quickly these facilities were set
up for mass producing her cells so these
giant industrial sized vats of culture
medium which is what you feed cells
assembly lines for putting them into
dishes and her cells were grown to the
tune of about 6 trillion cells a week
and sent out to laboratories around the
world so the volume of cells that grew
from this one little tiny sample is sort
of inconceivable one scientists
estimated that if you could have saved
them all and put them on a scale that by
today they'd weigh more than 50 million
metric tons and individual cells weigh
almost nothing so it's just it's so hard
to wrap your mind around how many cells
that is and they really changed science
they were one of the most important
things that happen to medicine they very
quickly were used to help develop the
polio vaccine they went up in the first
space missions to see what would happen
to human cells and zerogravity her cells
were the first ever cloned her genes
were some of the first ever mapped they
were used to create some of our most
important cancer medications like
vincristine and tamoxifen the HPV
vaccine we have thanks to her cells in
vitro fertilization a lot of the
technology for that was developed using
her cells the list just goes on and on
and Henrietta had no idea that the cells
were out there and part of what made
them so valuable for science was that
they grew with this intensity and they
did the same thing in her body so her
initial tumor which was about the size
of a nickel spread to almost every organ
in her body within just a few months and
she died just after his 31st birthday
and she left five kids behind they
didn't know anything about the cells
neither did her husband and they just
sort of went on with their lives they
lived in poverty in East Baltimore they
were pretty difficult lives
and they just never heard anything about
the cells until the 1970s
so flash forward a few decades and these
were the early days of gene mapping and
one scientist Victor McKusick who's sort
of known as the grandfather of the human
genome project and he was this
incredible geneticist at Hopkins he
decided to track down Henry at his kids
because he thought if he could get some
samples of their DNA then he could
essentially test their DNA and use that
to learn more about HeLa cells so he
sent a postdoc to call Henry at his
husband one day and Henry's husband had
a fourth-grade education he didn't know
what a cell was and the way he
understood this phone call was
essentially we've got your wife like
she's alive in a laboratory part of her
is alive in a laboratory we've been
doing research on her for the last 25
years and now we have to test your kids
to see if they have the cancer that
killed her none of which was what the
scientist said at all she said we want
to look at your kids HLA markers and
compare those of the HeLa cells I mean
things that most people wouldn't have
understood and his reference point the
only cell he'd ever heard of was like a
prison cell so he was like so they have
part of her or some of her in a cell
like a prison cell and part of what
happened in that moment was that just
linguistically he and the scientists
didn't understand each other there was a
sort of enormous communication breakdown
she was from China she hadn't been in
the u.s. very long a very thick accent
and David Lacs came from Southern
Virginia he spoke with a very thick
accent that his kids referred to as the
country mumble it was just like hose of
yeah it was very hard to understand him
till you got used to talking to him so
they just sort of literally didn't
understand each other but also you know
they spoke different languages in terms
of science and not science he really
didn't have the basic science education
to understand what she was saying and
she didn't realize that so she was very
well intentioned she was excited to talk
to him she thought HeLa cells were
amazing and Henrietta was famous and but
it was just this moment of complete
communication misfire so what he heard
was we have to test your kids to see if
they have cancer and for Henrietta's
kids particularly her daughter this was
terrifying so her daughter was
nearing her 30th birthday this is Deb
relax and she'd sort of lived her life
in fear of turning 30 because she knew
her mother died then didn't know why so
for her these scientists coming at this
point seemed like it confirmed her worst
fears so the scientists would come to
the house and take samples and Deborah
was this mixture of terrified about
finding out she had cancer but also very
excited because she thought maybe these
people can tell her about her mother
because she was a toddler when her mom
died and no one ever really talked about
her so the scientists would come to the
house and take these samples and Deborah
would say things like can you look in
these bits of my mother that you have
growing and tell me what her favorite
color was and whether she liked to dance
and if she breastfed me and she was also
very worried that her mother might
somehow be feeling pain because of this
research so she would as the scientist
sort of tried to explain some of the
research sure she would say things like
if you're shooting these bits of my
mother up to the moon and injecting them
with these chemicals does that somehow
hurt her in the afterlife can she rest
in peace if you're doing that and she
heard something about polio research and
sort of imagined her mother's spirit
experiencing all the physical pain of
polio in the afterlife and so she was
really worried that she needed to
protect her mother and she would ask the
scientist these questions and they just
had no idea how to respond to her one of
them gave her a medical school genetics
textbook and just sort of said here read
this this will tell you what you need to
know about your mother which it didn't
and this went on for years and pretty
soon scientists started hearing someone
has access to heelas kids and can I have
samples of their cells and DNA too and
so pretty soon their cells started being
sent out to scientists around the world
just like HeLa cells had pretty soon her
sons figured out that people were buying
and selling these cells and that in
addition to all the important science
that happens using them that they really
launched a multi-billion dollar industry
so many of the most important biotech
companies that are now out there sort of
supplying genes and cells and you know
patenting genes and all those things
started off as this very small company
that just started selling HeLa cells and
when they found that out they started
saying you know so if people are buying
and selling these things essentially
where's our cut
and if our mother sells were so
important to medicine why can't we go to
the doctor why don't we get access to
the medical care that her cells helped
create and no one had a very good answer
to that question for them and that in a
sense had kept going for many years
after that